many health care providers nationwide
are prescribing food instead of medicine
to tackle the obesity epidemic doctors
in more than a dozen states are moving
away from recommending surgery or pills
instead they're giving healthy food to
patients struggling with medical issues
related to their weight Jen Crawford is
at an urban farm in Washington DC which
sends produce to underserved communities
Jen good morning
well good morning so the produce that's
grown here by DC greens goes to city
residents who've been prescribed a
healthier diet by their doctors it is
part of this growing trend to help
low-income Americans get access to
healthier food and one Hospital in
central Pennsylvania is taking the
effort even further at Geisinger
Hospital in central Pennsylvania food
delivery start early turning these
medical professionals into temporary
grocers once you have the eggs it's all
part of a new fresh food pharmacy now
open in the heart of coal country where
shuttered mines have contributed to high
unemployment and rising poverty making
healthy eating a low priority and what's
your favorite fruit or vegetable that
you get from US beans the program was
created by dr. Andrea Feinberg Geisinger
Medical Director for health and wellness
we have a higher incidence of obesity a
higher incidence of diabetes and food
insecurity and what do you offer them so
we offer them hope we are offering a new
way to look at diabetes there are
pockets of communities around the United
States where the word has not gotten out
that food is really medicine started
just nine months ago the program already
serves more than 60 patients and their
families providing healthy food free of
charge to more than 200 people each week
along with nutrition classes and cooking
advice you're used to eating you know
pizza and burgers and french fries and
you come in here and there's kale in
quinoa that's a big transition do people
like it so people complain they may
complain
outside they first of all we asked him
just to be flexible try it you don't
like it no problem come back and tell us
we'll come up with new recipes Geisinger
is one of the first to set up a
standalone pharmacy but it draws
inspiration for more than 70 food
prescription programs across the country
all hoping to reverse a frightening
trend more than 100 million Americans
are either diabetic or pre-diabetic and
the Centers for Disease Control predicts
that by the year 2050 one in three
adults in the US could have diabetes we
haven't had turkey burger in a while
Rita Perkins has been diabetic for more
than 20 years after enrolling in the
food pharmacy program in March she cut
her blood sugar and cholesterol in half
he just made yourself some lunch yeah
that's a whole wheat tortilla pizza you
feel like this program is really making
a difference in your life it is how long
you think you'll stay with it probably
for the rest of my life dr. Feinberg
says Perkins results are not unique it's
over the top successful how that works
for every single patient it's worked for
every single patient that's a pretty
good success rate we're talking about
reversing the diabetes curing the type 2
diabetes and help the patients move
themselves from the sick category to the
healthy category now healthier food like
kale and tomatoes eggplant that may seem
expensive but guys Andres says that
despite providing it all for free
they're actually planning to save money
by cutting the long term medical cost in
fact the program has been so successful
they're already looking to expand to
about a dozen other locations across
Pennsylvania and New Jersey
Gayle Jan this is such an important
story people really need to understand
the difference that good food can make
good healthy food can make in your diet
I like to point the doctor made that
food is medicine exactly and that's the
program is proving that point I think
it's also fascinating that despite it
may be a little more expensive they're
going to save money in the long run
because it's going to cut down on
medical costs
at at you know attack it at the front
end yep I hear about this all the time
now because Nicole's nutritionist
because but it's your line it takes time
to get the mess
across and I think what if you make it
the right way can be it can taste good
the healthy food is you know Charlie yes
of course
beauty of a Brussels sprout and broccoli
you didn't like it as a kid but as you
get older you realize can really taste
pretty good so you about ready turned
vegan no are you doing it I'd be better
yes no I'm not going there just yet
Thank You Jan